bonjour thomas lors vladimir poutine est
arrivé tout à l'heure il a été reçu par
le premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
thomas on devrait savoir où on en est
dans le programme de la journée
eh bien écoutez le président de la
fédération de russie vient de
s'entretenir avec le président israélien
rivlin les deux hommes ont échangé
pendant quelques minutes devant les
caméras on a donc pu noter quelques
interventions du président russe qui a
notamment déclaré que 40 % des juifs
tués pendant la shoah étaient
originaires de l'union soviétique
vladimir poutine qui a expliqué qu'il
fallait faire attention à ne pas laisser
l'histoire se répéter il a par ailleurs
déclaré qu'il était nécessaire de
s'opposer à toute manifestation de
xénophobie et d'antisémitisme partout où
cela se passe
vladimir poutine qui devrait maintenant
assister à l'inauguration d'un monument
en mémoire des habitants de la ville de
leningrad assiégée et puis un peu plus
tôt dans la matinée le président russe a
rencontré le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou les deux hommes qui
se rencontraient régulièrement pour
preuve le premier ministre israélien
s'est rendu à 16 reprises en russie en
l'espace de dix ans je propose d'écouter
ces quelques mots du président russe
vladimir poutine lors de cet échange
chers collègues je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre invitation
nous travaillons de façon tout à fait
régulière avec le premier ministre et il
ya longtemps que nous étions convenus de
cette visite en israël et je suis
convaincu que cela ira au bénéfice de
nos relations bilatérales et bien au
chaud des moutons d'aujourd'hui nous
devons nous souvenir d'eux les victimes
de la shoah il monsieur premier ministre
et madame vous sarah je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre invitation
côté français emmanuel macron rencontre
ce matin la communauté française des
français donc établi en israël et puis
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui a fait le déplacement avec
le président de la république s'est
rendu dans un cimetière où des français
sont enterrés des français victimes du
terrorisme et de l'antisémitisme en
france
la journée va se poursuivre avec à 13h30
heure locale l'ouverture officielle du
forum du 5e forum de l'holocauste avec
des discours qui vont être prononcée par
un certain nombre de dirigeants
internationaux dont emmanuel macron dont
vladimir poutine benyamin netanyahou ou
encore le prince charles cette journée
qui est donc l'occasion également pour
des entretiens bilatéraux qui vont se
poursuivre en marge de cet événement un
mot enfin sur la sécurité dans la ville
de jérusalem il y à 49 délégations
internationales présentes ici c'est
selon la presse israélienne le plus
grand événement diplomatique jamais
organisé dans la ville alors évidemment
la sécurité a été particulièrement
renforcée 10000 forces de sécurité sont
déployés dans toute la ville aujourd'hui
comme un merci je rappelle que vous êtes
en direct de jérusalem